i brought up ethereum uh earlier you
said we can cover that as well yeah you
know there's a lot of guys that are pro
ethereum and you know they swear by now
if nft you know most of the purchases 50
is being done by ethereum ethereum's
eventually going to get a better than
bitcoin or you know ethereum's going to
be right there next to bitcoin what are
your thoughts on the theory
so first of all there's if you look at
the crypto ecosystem there's crypto
property there's crypto currencies
there's crypto platforms and this crypto
securities and there's even crypto art
right these are just asset classes maybe
they'll be crypto commodities nft is
crypto art it's like art
cryptographically protected
uh stable coin is cryptocurrency a
dollar or a euro moving on crypto rail
it's currency because i can move it as a
medium exchange without paying a tax
bill on it
um
ethereum's crypto platform right people
are building other things on that
platform and and that's the principal
appeal smart contracts and and the fact
that you can build something
bitcoin is crypto property
it is a long-term store of value
and um
and it is the dominant crypto property
and the way it establishes itself is
crypto property
is through nakamoto consensus and proof
of work you you have a decentralized
mining network that is encrypting energy
with the sha-256 hash function in order
to create
this wall of encrypted energy and and
make it uh resistant to denial of
service attacks other sorts of attacks
it needs to be robust
and have integrity over
over time and space and that's the
that's the technique that we've
developed now here's the big idea an
important idea most people don't
understand securities law
okay bitcoin's the only
proven
digital property that we have created in
the world we have we have created a
property and not a security
the definition of property is um
is a a common commodity that is beyond
the control of any one individual or
corporation if something is deemed
property uh in in a legal sense it means
it wouldn't be regulated by as a
security by the sec
um gold is property soybeans are
property wood lumber land is property
bitcoin is property
okay
um did the sec come out and officially
state that that it's not it's not a
securities it's officially a property
it's understood that bitcoin is not
regulated by the sec bitcoin is property
it's the only thing we all agree on in
the crypto marketplace that bitcoin is
property um
securities are regulated by the sec and
you can you can create a security
uh microstrategy mstr is a security
go read my 10k statements
123 pages of disclosures that are
legally required for that stock to trade
that security to trade
it cost 20 million dollars a year for us
to maintain all the disclosures to be
compliant with securities law if you're
a security it's a different thing
bitcoin is property
ethereum everything else in the crypto
ecosystem likely they're all securities
right why are they securities
they're controlled by
groups of developers they're issued
pursuant to ico's initial coin offerings
that make some security
if there's a pre mine and there was a
group of of individuals that initially
control the thing it makes it security
if um you know if anyone can exercise
undue influence it comes to security and
technically if you know if you look at
the definition it's
when you're making investment of money
uh relying upon the efforts of others
and expectation of profit it becomes an
investment contract
a security
okay the fundamental difference between
bitcoin and ethereum is
ethereum's monetary policy changes every
six months
every few months it changes there's a
difficulty bomb in ethereum that's been
getting pushed back since 2016. they
keep pushing it back when it goes off it
will wipe out obliterate a 50 billion
dollar ethereum mining industry
just wipe it out completely change the
protocol flip everything to proof of
stake
they keep putting it off okay that
sounds like a group of people exercising
influence over the protocol
the thing you need to know about bitcoin
is on pizza day
may 22nd 2010
bitcoin is trading for a couple of
pennies for the first time in
15 months or or something like that
the protocol
hadn't changed and has not changed
it when it was a penny the protocols
were all the same
today they're the same exact protocol
there was a war
fought over this the block size war
and the block size war
all of the powerful holders and miners
and exchanges wanted to change
the protocol and double the block size
it would have changed all the economics
of bitcoin forever for the next thousand
years it would have screwed up the
economics of the miners
it would have shifted the balance of
power in favor of of of some holders
versus others
that war was lost the original bitcoin
protocol uh continued on and that means
it's an
unadulterated uh protocol and it's shown
itself to be resistant to the influence
of of any group of people that's what
makes it property
property is critical because prop
if property makes bitcoin being property
makes it the ethical foundation of the
crypto economy
and by ethical foundation i mean
it's unethical for a public figure to
endorse a security
if you're the mayor of a city the
governor of a state if you're a
politician a congressman a senator
a president of a nation
you can't endorse a security nor can you
make a security underpinning of the
balance sheet
of a public
a public organization right it's like i
couldn't say i really think that every
citizen of kansas city should buy
twitter stock because it's a better
store of value
it's conflict of interest it's probably
illegal
it probably violates all sorts of
foreign corrupt practices acts
as well as all the ethics laws
and so this this is a very bright line
property versus security and as soon as
you start to exercise influence over the
protocol
it becomes a security
if you look at all the cryptos
you know there might be a dozen that you
could debate a property a debate of the
ones that you could debate a property
there's one that's dominant which is
bitcoin
there's 17 000 securities
as the sec
and the regulators move there's gonna be
a massive shakeout
if they ever do clarify what the
securities laws are
there's a whole set of disclosures and
obligations and then
and then uh you're going to see
you know the entire industry rationalize
in a big way so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]